Hello.
We're going to talk about the subject called,
Ketosis, What is it?
Ketosis is a state of fat-burning, so when
you're in ketosis, you're making something
called ketones.
What are ketones?
Ketones are those things that, it's a type
of fuel for the body that's alternative fuel
than actual sugar or glucose.
Ketones would be like riding a car using electricity
versus diesel fuel, which is more sugar, so
it's a cleaner fuel source.
It's an alternative fuel source that will
give a person way more energy than glucose.
Even professional athletes can far outrun
and perform on ketosis than the carbo-loading.
Okay.
Now what's the premises of ketosis?
The premise of ketosis is lowering your insulin
or your sugars, which is refined carbohydrates
way, way, way down there, to close to zero.
Like 5% of your daily calories.
Let me explain what insulin is though.
Insulin is the hormone that regulates sugar.
Normally, in your blood you only store, in
your entire body, two little teaspoons of
sugar.
That's all you store.
That's all you have in your blood, so our
bodies were not designed to consume the amount
of sweet or sugar that we consume.
I mean, the average person eats 145 pounds
a year, so that's just insane.
Anything more than two teaspoons is going
to be very toxic to the body.
So, on an average person, they're consuming
so much carbohydrate.
Well, the body will just jack up insulin.
It's like a whiplash response, and then get
it out of the blood fast and stick it into
the liver, and start building up fat around
the liver.
That's what it does, so all these people with
a fatty liver, with high cholesterol, high
blood fats, that is the sugar in their diet.
It's not coming from the fat in the diet.
Our bodies make a lot of cholesterol, 2,000
milligrams a day.
It's not that.
In fact, here's some interesting things.
The good benefits of being in ketosis, which
by the way, is lowering your carbs, increasing
your dietary fats, and having a moderate amount
of protein.
Is it will lower your bad cholesterol.
It increases your good cholesterol.
It lowers your triglycerides.
It improves blood sugars.
Improves insulin resistance.
Now, there are studies that will tell you
that it worsens.
If you eat fat, it'll worsen diabetes or insulin
resistance and that has to do with the type
of study that they did.
They did it on rats and they used corn oil.
They didn't use healthy fats.
Corn oil is not only genetically modified,
but it's not a healthy fat, so I'm not surprised
that that made things worse.
So, you really want to, when you see these
studies that say that something is bad, actually
read what they're using as their fats or their
foods, and you'll find that even that they
just study on vitamins, and they used synthetic
vitamins versus natural.
I was kind of our suspect, unless I read the
study myself.
Improve memory, improve dementia, good blood
sugar levels, reducing acne.
Reducing cancer risk, why?
Because, sugar feeds cancer.
In fact, there's even certain types of scans
that they do to detect cancer and they look
for areas of your body that you're consuming
excess sugar, because cancer is very hungry
for sugar.
So, why not just cut the sugar out and decrease
the risk?
Decreased polycystic ovarian syndrome.
So, what is that?
That's a condition where a female has a lot
of these little follicles that are growing
on the ovaries, and it's pumping out too much
of the wrong hormone, the male hormone, and
they're getting acne, loss of hair.
A lot of issues, but that will reduce, if
you're on this eating plan.
It decreases inflammation.
I mean, how many people have inflammation?
So, sugar will promote inflammation.
Also, digestive bloating.
This is very good for digestion.
Now, the healthy fats that you need to be
on are basically grass-fed animal products.
Like beef, or something like that.
Do not consume the lean beefs, or the turkey
bacon, or the chicken without the skin.
Why?
Because, we need those healthy fats.
Do not eat eggs without the yolks.
We need that fat to be able to get you in
ketosis.
But, I know the concern.
The concern is, "Oh, my gosh.
I don't want to clog my arteries."
We've been, literally, brainwashed to think
that it's bad for your arteries.
All I'm going to tell you is try it for a
couple weeks.
Go get your blood test, and you will see that
it will go down, and you'll be ... I mean,
your bad cholesterol will go down, your heart
will be clean, and you'll have to prove it
to yourself.
I'm going to list the studies underneath this
video, but I want you, personally, to experience
the benefits of this.
Because, long-term for health, this running
at your body on sugar, you're not going to
last.
If you combine sugar with protein, you create
even worse problems with insulin and that's
why when I have people that say, "Well, I'm
eating mostly healthy, everything in moderation,"
but they have just enough sugar in there to
cause, bump them out of ketosis, so all that
saturated fat will plug up their arteries,
because they have just enough to nullify the
benefits.
Okay.
We have a lot of benefits.
We don't want to combine carbohydrates or
too much protein, but I created a link below
that lists the eating plan that I would recommend,
types of foods that you should be on to be
able to get yourself into ketosis.
You'll be hearing a lot more of this in the
upcoming news.
By athletes, by researchers, because it is
true and it creates a lot of benefits.
There's a couple little twists to it.
For example, if you've been running your body
on sugar for so long, it takes a little bit
to trans adapt your body to this new fuel
source.
In that transition, you might have to take
it gradual, because you're not used to it.
Some people, because sugar really holds so
much fluid, you might drop a lot of water
weight initially, and you also might lose
a little too much sodium.
So, you might need to consume more salt on
this diet to be able to keep the blood pressure
up, because it lowers blood pressure and then
you'll feel better, but when you start dumping
all this fat and all this water off your body,
and you might feel a little lightheaded, you
just might need a little bit more salt.
So, I suggest you push through it.
It's only a transition phase, but running
your body on ketones is much healthier long-term.
Apply what I just told you and make some comments
underneath this video.